Fishing with dynamite, or blast fishing as
it’s more accurately known, despite sounding
like something more suited to a Looney Tunes
cartoon, is a genuine and well-documented
practice that is still commonplace in select
areas of the globe today.
This is more than a little unfortunate for
the many fish and marine animals that call
the oceans and lakes their home due to the
invariably cataclysmic impact the practice
has on local aquatic ecosystems.
Exactly when blast fishing first began is
hard to pinpoint, but it should come as no
surprise that it seems to have become popular
within decades of dynamite being invented
in 1867 (incidentally invented by Alfred Nobel,
known today for the Nobel Prizes, but in his
time as “the merchant of death”).
While someone probably fished using improvised
or homemade explosives prior to the invention
of dynamite, the creation of a commercially
available, relatively safe to handle and inexpensive
explosive made it an option for the wider
public.
As for the first documented references to
this method of fishing, while it is certain
that there were many earlier instances, the
first we could find was an 1894 reference
to a man being arrested for the crime of blast
fishing, as reported in the New York Democratic
Herald:
John Tickwich was arrested at Binnewater for
destroying fish in one of the Binnewater lakes
with dynamite.
He had just exploded a number of cartridges,
killing several hundred fish, and was gathering
them into his boat when arrested.
The prisoner will be taken before the State
Game Protectors of Albany.
Five years is the penalty for the crime.
Another early reference to blast fishing likewise
comes from it being banned, this time in Hong
Kong.
In 1898, the government asked fishermen to
stop blast fishing and that the fisherman
police themselves over the matter.
The governor also issued the following statement
to fishermen: “The practice of fishing by
means of dynamite is unnecessarily destructive
and contrary to the spirit of true sport.”
As you might imagine, little seems to have
changed as a result of this request, so the
government stepped up their game on the issue,
officially outlawing blast fishing in Hong
Kong in 1903.
Despite the governments of the world seemingly
realising blast fishing was a bad idea pretty
much right from the start, this method of
fishing’s popularity quite literally exploded
throughout the world thanks to WW1 and WW2.
Soldiers from both sides of each conflict
made extensive use of explosives in fishing
while stationed in foreign countries, a practice
locals took notice of and copied.
As an example of this, Japanese soldiers stationed
in the Pacific during World War 2 are noted
to have given out hand grenades to locals
to be used for fishing.
In return, the locals were required to share
the fish they’d catch with the soldiers.
As a result of this, many Pacific islanders
became incredibly adept in the handling of
various explosive devices.
This is knowledge they put to use after the
war, taking advantage of the numerous explosives
left behind to construct their own makeshift
fishing bombs.
For instance, on the small island nation of
Palau, even as late as the 1960s, huts could
be found containing large caches of undetonated
WW2 explosives, with the compounds within
the devices, or the devices themselves, slated
to be later used for fishing.
As the availability of unused munitions from
World War 2 dwindled, the islanders began
to use more commercially available explosives
or, more often for small time fishermen, simply
constructed their own using readily available
materials.
For instance, former blast fisherman Abdul
Karim Laing noted that all one needs is a
bit of fertilizer, gasoline, matchsticks,
and a beer bottle to make a very effective
explosive for fishing with.
But as you might imagine, such home-made bombs
can be very dangerous and fishing in this
way tends to make the practice not only devastating
for marine life, but occasionally for the
humans doing the fishing as well.
fishermanFor instance Mwanya Sleiman, a former
blast fisherman in Tanzania who has since
become a staunch opponent of the practice,
accidentally blew off both of his hands when
a home-made explosive detonated when he was
trying to light the fuse.
As for why he used to fish this way, he noted,
“My motivation was just the money I got
from selling the fish but I didn’t know
about the impact it would have on me or the
underwater environment.”
Speaking of Tanzania, blast fishing is outlawed
there due to it not only negatively impacting
tourism, but also because they’ve seen a
drastic decline in fish stock as a result.
As one Tanzanian fisherman lamented,
Blast fishing destroys the fish habitats under
water where fish reproduce and that has had
a big impact, especially on us who use ring
nets to fish…
The number of fish has drastically reduced
we are not able to catch many fish like before…
He also stated that reporting blast fishing
did little good in the region because “When
[the blast fishermen] are arrested, they bribe
and come back, and if they find out that you
reported them they mark you and threaten to
hurl explosives on your boat, so sometimes
we are scared to report them.”
Speaking of this, while blast fishing is technically
outlawed by most countries of the world, it
remains incredibly popular in places such
as the Philippines, Indonesia and coastal
African nations both due to the general apathy
of local law enforcement and how much easier
it is in the short term to get a big catch
this way.
The latter point is, of course, the key reason
blast fishing is considered so difficult to
stamp out.
When a fisherman can acquire what would otherwise
be his entire daily quota of fish using more
traditional netting methods in a few minutes
by hucking a few well-placed, extremely inexpensive
explosive devices into the ocean, there’s
little incentive for many of them to do it
the hard way.
We can scoff at the shortsightedness of these
individuals, but it’s important to note
that many are completely ignorant of the long
term damage they’re doing to the fisheries
they depend on.
And even for those who know, they have families
to feed, often with few resources to do it,
and may not be overly concerned about what
will happen years down the line if they continue
blast fishing.
So what’s the problem with blast fishing?
To begin with, as alluded to previously, there
is the danger posed to the fishermen (often
using home-made explosives) and potential
swimmers and scuba divers (particularly a
problem in touristy coastal areas).
Another big problem is the efficiency of this
method of fishing.
Blast fishing works by bursting the air bladders
and sometimes other organs of the fish in
the immediate area.
The result is that some of the fish float
to the surface to be collected.
However, it’s estimated that approximately
ten times that amount go the other way and
sink to the bottom as a result of the ruptured
air bladders.
Beyond this all being incredibly inefficient,
it should also be noted that according to
one fish trader in Tanzania’s Dar es Salaam
fish market, she tries to stay away from blast
fishing caught fish, because she claims the
fish caught in this way “rot very fast – by
the time you get home they are rotten.
Some buyers and sellers don’t know that
so they buy them.”
But these aren’t the biggest problems with
blast fishing.
For that, we have to look at what the blasting
does to the ecosystem of a relatively large
area around the explosion.
Explosives are, by their very nature, somewhat
imprecise in their targeting, making the act
of fishing with them unsustainable as they
will invariably destroy countless other marine
creatures besides the fish, as well as their
underlying habitats like coral reefs.
Most critical for the fishermen, this ultimately
destroys the habitat for the fish themselves.
This means the fish that survive in the area
now have fewer resources to live on, and in
many cases their normal breeding grounds are
destroyed, further reducing the fish population
beyond what the initial blast does.
Unsurprisingly from this, as with Tanzania,
areas where blast fishing is prevalent tend
to see a rapid decline in fish stock.
Nevertheless, blast fishing remains a problem
in some regions, even where authorities have
made a concerted effort to crack down on it.
That said, perhaps the cleverest way to stop
blast fishermen we could find was implemented
in the Philippines where authorities dropped
statuettes of the Virgin Mary underwater across
the country’s coastline and announced it
to the public.
This cut instances of blast fishing almost
overnight as many fisherman from the predominantly
Catholic region didn’t dare risk harming
an image of one of the most revered figures
of
their faith.